[موسيقى]
افغانستان بين اجد الحكومه في كابول وتشدد
القياده في قندهار يغرق شعبها يوما بعد
الاخر في الجهل والفقر كيف لا وقد قررت
قياده طالبان منع الفتيات والنساء من
الدراسه بجميع مستوياتها في تراجع عن
التزاماتها بحفظ حقوق المراه
هرموا السلطه في طالبان موزع بين كابو
العاصمه البلاد
وقندهار مسقط راس مؤسس الحركه الملا عمر
واغلب قادتها الحاليين هناك وهم هبه الله
اخون زاد زعيم الحركه عبد الحكيم حقاني
قاضي القضاه الملا محمد حسن اخوند رئيس
الوزراء نور محمد ثقب وزير الحج والارشاد
حبيب الله اغا وزير التعليم العام نداء
محمد نديم وزير التعليم العالي
هذه الاسماء الموجوده في قندهار تقف وراء
القرارات الاخيره ضد المراه خاصه زعيم
الحركه الذي يحتفظ بالكلمه الاخيره في
جميع قرارات السياسه الوطنيه الرئيسيه
الامر الذي يثير حفيظه وجوه اخرى في حركه
طالبان تتبنى التوجه الاصلاحيه وترى ان
الدوده لا جدوى منه
اداره الحكومه والبلاد لا تصلح بالتشدد
والتطرف والشعب وضع امله فينا وجعلنا نصب
اعينه نحن الافغان هزمنا ثلاثه
امبراطوريات اليس من العار علينا ان نمد
ايدينا الى امريكا لطلب المساعدات نحن امه
المجاهده ونطلب من الكفار الاكل هذا يظهر
هناك افغان عديم كرامه
ومهما يكن من امر فان قرارات طالبان
الاخيره
اعادت البلاد للمواجهه الداخليه
والمحتمله مع الخارج ما يعني ان مشوار
افغانستان ما يزال طويلا للوصول الى نقطه
الاستقرار انسنا الناسي العربيه
[موسيقى]